[Music]
the existence of home court advantage is
one of the most
durable empirical patterns in all of
sports however
the relative importance of mechanisms
explaining its strength
such as fan attendance still remains a
mystery
capacity restrictions during the
2020-2021 nba season
allow us an opportunity to identify the
effect of crowds on home court advantage
over the course of 440 games played in
front of empty arenas during the season
the home team won by an average of 0.39
points
this is in stark contrast to the 2.13
average point margin
during the more than 500 games played
with crowds
this is a similar effect to starting an
all-star
over an average nba player in short
the data say exactly what any passionate
fan
already knows fans matter
so next time your favorite basketball
team geeks out at one point when at home
you have proof that your spirited
cheering really did make the difference
between winning
and losing how important do you think
fans are for home court advantage
let us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos
from aei